hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video leute
ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut wir haben
uns heute hier zusammengefunden um etwas
neues auszuprobieren
ich hatte das schon länger im kopf
beziehungsweise jemand anderes hat mir
die idee mal vorgeschlagen und ich fand
es eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht
influenza marketing boumtje aktuell so
wie noch nie zuvor hat und es gibt
tausende gut das bisschen viel
vielleicht es gibt auf jeden fall jede
menge produkte in deutschland die man
kennen weil irgendwelche -influenza
große influenza viele influenza dieses
produkt beworben haben und viel ist halt
auch einfach scheiße deswegen dachte ich
mir weil ich immer sachen teste frage
ich das euch da draußen mal auf
instagram könnt ihr mir sehr gerne
folgende hat sich alex wie welche
produkte habt ihr mal bestellt weil sie
von influenza beworben wurden und findet
sie nicht so gut die resonanz darauf war
riesig ich kann euch das sehr gerne
einbinden und es sind echt so ein paar
marken rausgestochen die viele leute
gelernt haben und ich dachte mir wir
starten einfach mal nur drei produkten
drei marken rein die man kennt weil sie
von in flames angeworben wurden
safe also die kennst du nicht weil die
im fernsehen werbung machen die kennt
man auf jeden fall durch krasses
influenza marketing ich werde ganz
unvoreingenommen rangehen ja ich hab
nichts von diesen sachen umsonst bekomme
ich habe alles selber gekauft und wird
auch meine meinung sagen wenn ich es
nicht so gut finde ich schon gesagt habe
heute drei sachen einmal ist dass er
dann haben wir bei food und ocean spa
oceans partner freue mich ganz besonders
drauf hat auch schon sympathisch geht
nicht an dir vorbei wenn du einmal in
server auf mach das ding hier ist er
bekannt durch die höhle der löwen aber
dann halt auch durch influenza und ich
glaube mittlerweile mehr durch influenza
bekannt als durch die höhle der löwen so
ich hab da einfach mal bestellt für 40
euro knapp 40 euro
das r ab starterpaket hier ist einmal
diese flasche mit drin und dann noch
diese geschmacks länger hier die kann
man da oben drauf ploppen hier ist jetzt
dabei lasse ich mal kurz schauen einmal
die trinkflasche und zweimal orientation
flut leim ich hätte sehr gern noch so
ein cola geschmack oder so gehabt aber
habe ich heute nicht bestellt das sollte
aber auch erst mal reichen an die nicht
wissen was das ist du gibst wasser rein
in die trinkflasche packs an eins von
diesen petz obendrauf und trinkst die
ganze zeit wasser aber dadurch dass
dieser pad geruch glaube ich in der nase
kommen soll das halt dazu anregen dass
du denkst du trinkst cola oder
orangensaft oder was weiß ich ich muss
sagen die idee dahinter finde ich genial
ich hab das sogar damals bei die höhle
der löwen
viele haben heute geschrieben dass es
irgendwie kacke ist das hat ich weiß
nicht also kann ich mir eigentlich kaum
vorstellen lustigerweise kann ich auch
dazu sagen ich wurde auch vor 23 monaten
ende letzten jahres mal von den
angefragt um eine kooperation mit den
einzugehen hat nicht geklappt also ist
nicht zustande gekommen wegen
verschiedenen gründen aber deswegen
freue ich mich jetzt umso mehr das
einfach mal für euch zu testen und ich
sag euch selbst meine ehrliche meinung
dazu im internet gibt es auch massenhaft
positive als auch negative kritiken dazu
haben wir uns denke ich auch noch mal
kurz an
aber ich will das jetzt erstmal testen
ich starte mit orange passion fruit das
ist mir irgendwie lieber oder das recht
auf jeden fall schon sehr intensiv will
ich mal ein bisschen wasser weit dann
kommt das hier obendrauf deine er ab
flasche kann beliebig oft mit
leitungswasser nachgefüllt werden einer
der kleinen potts reicht für mindestens
fünf liter natürliches wasser er jetzt
bin ich wirklich mal gespannt
ich probiere es einfach mal und dann
sage ich mehr dazu mach ich da irgendwas
falsch
ja ich hatte den schon drauf aber da
habe ich ja gar nichts gerochen hier
ich richte da bisher nur rang aber das
ist weg doch nur noch wasser ich weiß
das habe ich ja auch also das war mir
bewusst aber ich finde es wirklich echt
los
das hier ist ein special flut ich kann
auch noch mal einen drauf tun
ich nehme jetzt noch mal ein hier
vielleicht ist das ja besser ja gut das
richtige heim richtet auf jeden fall
schon intensiver muss ich sagen jetzt
problem was nochmal ja also ich kann die
leute verstehen die sagen das ist das
ist irgendwie lane ist so aber so ein
bisschen es ist halt es ist neues wasser
trinken das stimmt aber das kostet
kummer ich finde das auch ein bisschen
teuer muss ich sagen 40 40 euro für eine
trinkflasche und so ein bisschen geruch
hier und er ist nach fünf litern finde
ich eigentlich was du hast halt die
markentypische dabei und kriegst auch
dadurch extrem zählweise und das heißt
ihr problem was ich sehe ist wichtig
dass das zu wenig reinpassen liter
benzin geiler muss voll auf das ist mir
aber ich bin also eine flasche bestelle
ich dir auch aus china für zwei euro 99
die sie genauso aus guten leute um nicht
unfair zu sein habe ich gerade mal einen
erfahrenen und begeisterten er ab nutzer
dazu geschaltet felix flexibel wenn ich
euch jemand foto einen der ist sehr
angetan von den dingern ich muss sagen
für mich persönlich 40 euro für so was
und ich habe es mir schon ein bisschen
krasser vorgestellt es riecht halt schon
nach laim oder orange aber um husmann
jetzt nicht vielleicht muss ich nochmal
cola bestellt oder so schreibt super
gerne eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare
aber ich finde so für 15 euro ok 20 euro
vielleicht auch aber fusions bisschen
zuviel ganz wichtig das ist nur meine
meinung und ich möchte hier ist halt
einfach nur ein kleiner test so leute da
bin ich wieder wir haben schon den
übernächsten tag weil ich musste auf die
anderen beiden produkte noch warten
wollen ausschusses partner ein bisschen
los das wird mit dpd verschickt und er
hat einfach mein haus nicht gefunden
weswegen ich mir jetzt anderweitig viele
aus
produkte besorgt aber das ist egal wir
staat jetzt erstmal mit weib habe ich
bestellt bei amazon glück mal und ich
hatte mir aus dem messer bestellt aber
das brauche ich jetzt gar nicht wollte
so kurz mal so tun und hier haben wir
jetzt ein probiert drin
das sind drei getränke für unfassbare 20
euro einmal haben wir hier vanille
dann haben wir doku ladegewicht oder
alsdorf altintop und hier ist noch fresh
perry hätte ja ich weiß auch nicht also
ein getränk kostet schon mal sechs euro
66 periode ich muss sagen vom designer
haft gefallen die mir das sieht schon
echt nice aus nun schon ein bisschen
teurer wobei wäre weise kann man glaube
ich auf fünf produkte ich habe das jetzt
mit prime bestellt sonst hätte ich auch
für fünf von diesen drinks nur 20 euro
bezahlen trotzdem natürlich auch ein
stolzer preis darauf ruht ist eine
leckere und ausgewogene trink mal zeit
also soll eine mahlzeit ersetzen
26 vitamine und minerale reich antworte
ihnen ballaststoffe laktosefrei
glutenfrei ohne zuckerersatz ich muss
sagen ich habe extra heute mittag nichts
gegessen wir haben jetzt 12 52 und ich
habe mir jetzt einfach mal diesen
vanille trinken und mal gucken ob ich
danach noch hunger habe erstmal werde
ich checke wieder überhaupt schmeckt
riecht auf jeden fall sehr nach einem
vanille eiweiß shake ich hatte ja auch
mal meine fitness phase da habe ich
immer ein spektrum das riecht ungefähr
gleich oder ein problem aber ist
eigentlich lecker muss ich sagen wie
viel ist denn hier drinnen 330
milliliter
was haben wir ja schnell weg
so das war es auch schon also wenn es
mal schnell gehen muss dann geht es auf
jeden fall auch sehr schnell
ich frag mich jetzt nur reicht das für
mich oder habe ich gleich trotzdem
hunger ich habe mir jetzt gerade hier
nochmal die website angeschaut und wenn
ich das bestellen würde sechs flaschen
0,5 alpin chocolate zahl ich knapp 21
euro das wären also pro drink drei euro
fünfzig was ich dann okay findet safe
also das wird auf jeden fall klar dass
sie weiß also ein probierpaket 0,33
deswegen trinke ich hier von jetzt auch
einfach mal noch die hälfte hinterher
weil dann ist es ja so als würde ich
wirklich eine 0,5 war lose trinken okay
ist keine dose arbeit war oder das
riecht aber lecker das schmeckt auch gut
jetzt im probieren wir noch hier
chocolat einmal alles durch wenn schon
denn schon
das war ich gar nicht also alpin lodge
weg mit längst nicht so gut wie fresh
perry und fuß vanilla ich habe jetzt auf
jeden fall ungefähr ein halber liter
davon zu mir genommen
wir stellen das jetzt mal beiseite dann
kann ich euch gleich sagen ob das mir
gereicht hat weil wenn man so ein
allzeit beschäftigter business mann ist
wie ich dann ist es natürlich auch sehr
sehr wichtig mal schnell mittag zu essen
um danach direkt wieder die dicken
placement abzusagen apropos voll
outplacement mit media markt habe ich
noch keins aber ich habe hier eine 1000
euro wundertüte bestellt von denen bin
ich mal gespannt ob sich die ilo und so
und jetzt können wir hier zum absoluten
verriet wir haben eine riesige auswahl
die haben auch einige wenige männer
sachen aber ich dachte mir das macht
eigentlich keinen sinn weil du gehst auf
instagram und du siehst mindestens
einmal direkt aus super jede
zwölfjährige tickt lockeren mit über
einer million abonnenten wird direkt mit
einem ausschuss hat diehl sagen wir
jetzt mal nicht abgezockt aber
ausgestattet also wenn du tickt lockeren
bis in deutschland und voller hass du
musst auf jeden fall auf produkte von
ausfahrt in einem kleiderschrank haben
irgendwie sieht das ein bisschen klein
aus aber ich glaube dass stretched sich
so ich muss fairerweise sagen an sich
finde ich die sachen schön meine
freundin marie die trick das auch im
lokal habe ich überhaupt nichts
auszusetzen also auch schon separat war
wirklich die marke die von euch am
häufigsten genannt wurde und dann halt
auch mit dem hinblick darauf dass die
qualität schlecht ist weiß ich jetzt
nicht also ich bin kein textil experte
aber an sich macht das erste mal gute
eindrücke okay hier kann ich doch sagen
das ist jetzt so ein lila set mit
oberteil das oberteil geht noch klar
hier merkt man schon dass die quali
jetzt nicht so bombastisch ist
es ist nicht grottenschlecht das ding
ist nur die preise sind immer offensiv
wirklich krass und ich habe sage ich mal
ich respektiere dass wir die arbeiten
und es ist halt auch einfach ein
geschäftskonzept zu generieren aber wenn
wir uns hier mal die website anschauen
da fällt einem auch direkt auf die
arbeiten halten wirklich überall mit
diesen kassen rabatten über 19 90 euro
runtergesetzt auf 79 euro das sind nicht
irgendwelche auslaufmodelle das ist
wirklich überall so und keine ahnung das
finde ich schon ein bisschen kacke hier
habe ich jetzt zum beispiel dieses etwas
wir hier liegen haben das ist das fazit
für 80 euro es wird wahrscheinlich auch
viele die jetzt sagen werden alex das
sehe ich anders aber ich muss sagen ich
finde so eine trinkflasche von er ab für
40 euro dann ein bisschen weniger
gerechtfertigt also ein ausschuss im
fazit für 80 euro wobei das auch recht
natürlich teuer ist und ich bin mir auch
ziemlich sicher dass es bessere qualität
weniger geld wird aber es ist halt eine
krasse marketing strategie die die da
fahren auch mit diesen ganzen
rabattcodes auf instagram du bist ja
zugeballert und du christ von jeder
influenza denn wieder den rabattcode und
rabattcode und rabattcode denn christ
noch einmal 20 prozent runter und
irgendwo hat man da bestimmt auch mal
einen guten deal machen es ist ja jedem
von euch selbst überlassen ob man da
bestellt aber ich persönlich kann jetzt
erst mal nichts gegen aussen seebad
sagen auch wenn das jetzt selber nicht
so mein favourit marke wäre ich muss
sagen gefährlich also trage ich jetzt
öfter ins gym kann man leute und das nun
mal ganz kurz auf den punkt zu bringen
also ich finde sonst für 80 euro standen
mit der qualität viel zu teuer ich habe
gerade mal ein bisschen recherchiert
es gibt eine menge gutschein
konsolidieren so bis zu 40 prozent und
da ist es auch so du bestellst für 70
euro und kriegs dann 1 hat gratis das
finde ich dann okay sonst zu teuer das
habe ich im video nicht klar genug
gesagt
deswegen halten wir fest bei foot feiere
ich sehr daumen nach oben von mir 350 im
schnitt trinkt mahlzeit und ich bin gut
gesagt ich glaube ich dabei auch schon
sympath ist jetzt nicht der überschuss
aber es ist okay und er feiere ich nicht
also das ist so der verliererseite
ich habe das wirklich in den letzten
beiden tagen auch noch öfter mal benutzt
und dadurch auf jeden fall schon ein
bißchen mehr wasser getrunken trotzdem
es ist halt einfach bisher nur ja ja das
war es mit dem ersten part ich bin super
gespannt treibt gerne in die kommentare
oder schickt mir bei instagram weitere
marken die von influenza stark beworben
werden vielleicht auch beim nächsten mal
wirklich produkte von innen
das habe ich jetzt natürlich nicht so
wirklich behandelt und dann teste man
das mal ausgiebig ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen abonniert den kanal hast du
nach oben da und wir sehen und
übermorgen wieder haut rein